FEMALE SPEAKER: Please
join me in welcoming Nancy.
[APPLAUSE]
NANCY HACHISU: So I just
took one little, small swath
off the top of
Japanese pickling.
We have pickling, and
we have preserving,
but those words don't actually
represent the true meaning.
"Tsukemono" equals "pickling,"
but it's not really equal.
"Tsukemono" means putting
something on-- "tsukeru"--
and so, putting on
something that--
things that have had
something put onto them.
And those can often be,
like, a really quick pickle,
30 minutes.
And that's what
we're doing today.
Preserving typically
is-- I mean,
it does involve some fruits.
But like a Western
idea of preserves,
you start thinking
the jam thing.
I think more of the preserving
in Japan is done with fish,
but then, also, some
vegetables and fruits.
But we can't do that today.
We're going to do some quick
pickles, just super easy.
They're incredibly delicious.
I will say they're most
delicious if you use
the best ingredients possible.
And I think that's
kind of a no-brainer.
They're using preserved
foods to quick pickle,
so that's where the
preserving comes in.
Of course, salt's not preserved.
But this was made slowly
by a guy I know in Wajima.
And the sweetness of
the salt comes out
when you take the
crystals off slowly.
And all this stuff is
going to get passed around.
You can taste it.
So the salt is sweet and salty.
And so it makes
it really gentle.
We used Maldon today, in the
stuff that you're going to eat.
So we have four salts in Japan,
salt-- these other things all
have salt in them, of course.
Oops, I lost my top to the
miso-- soy sauce-- this soy
sauce is made in our town.
It's organic, made
from Japanese beans
and aged two years, cedar
barrels, all organic.
And mostly, I know a lot of the
people that grow the soybeans
for these, and the wheat.
You can buy this soy sauce here,
in this bottle, Nama Shoyu.
I bought it in Tokyo
Fish in Berkeley.
It's not always taken
care of very well.
Like, some of the bottles
at Tokyo fish were weeping.
I didn't tell them yet.
What can you do?
So I bought the non-weepy
one, just because I
wanted to compare it and see.
And I was wondering--
I was worried
I was going to use it all up.
I was at Stanford
a couple days ago,
and I almost the whole bottle.
But we are bringing this in.
I'm involved in a project,
the Japan Brand Project.
The Japanese government's
trying to better the ingredients
that you can get here, and
then also, of course, EU
and the rest of the world.
But the US is the first target.
OK?
And then, miso, you
guys all know miso.
Sadly, we still are not
getting good miso here.
I don't know why.
This is also coming.
This is sold by the
same people that sell
this, Gold Mine Natural Foods.
Your best source
for Japanese foods
is macrobiotic
sites, because they
came in the early '70s, George
Ohsawa and Kushi, those people,
MUSO, and they brought
in the best products.
And unfortunately, the
Japanese grocery stores sort of
missed the boat on that.
And so their products
are-- they didn't
get-- the artisanal
products were not really
so much available at the time.
And then, they're so many
generations off they've-- they
haven't really added
artisanal products very much,
in my viewpoint.
So the miso around,
that you get,
has some additives,
like alcohol.
The Gold Mine one, it's the
same thing, but it's oxidized,
so it's super dark.
Doesn't mean it's bad.
These things never go
bad, they just darken.
Even if they have a date, a
sell date or best by date,
forget about it.
It's good for 100 years.
Then, this is fish sauce.
Japanese fish sauce is the
best in the world, hands down.
I've tasted it against the
really good Italian colatura,
and it's better.
You'll got to taste this around.
And we're putting it-- but
the ones you're tasting,
it's things that you
can taste at Google.
And so you're going to try to
compare what you're getting,
and then, also, what
could be you getting.
So that's a little
intellectual exercise for you.
It's not to say
you can't have it.
And I'll introduce
those products after.
OK.
So salt's here.
The first thing we're
going to do is dashi.
I will tell you,
the sad story is
that I don't use
induction very much,
but I think I can handle this.
The sad story is
that-- I got it.
I got it.
I'm on top of it.
I have a Stanford
degree, B.A. It's OK.
I can do it.
Can't do my taxes,
but I can do this.
OK.
We're going to put
a piece of kombu
in-- how many cups
of water did I put?
I can't remember--
four cups of water.
And you bring it
to almost simmer.
Then you're going to
take the kombu out.
And then you're going to put a
couple handfuls of katsuobushi
in.
Katsuobushi's dried,
smoked-- smoked-- smoked,
dried, fermented skipjack tuna.
Unfortunately, what
you get here has never
been the six-month
period of smoking
and drying-- no, no,
drying and fermenting.
They're all smoked, but the
drying, fermenting extra six
months is only from the whole
ones, which is in my bag.
We'll jump it out later, OK?
And you'll get to
taste this too.
I'll pass it around.
And I'll pass the whole
one too, but it's in there.
And it's a 16-minute process,
but 60% of the Japanese
do actually make dashi--
you've got to factor that in.
60% percent of the ones that
actually make dashi-- they
use powdered.
So food traditions
are eroding rapidly.
And that's part of why the
Japanese government is trying
to get better Japanese
products out to the other areas
to make Japanese feel like
maybe it's a reverse exportation
thing.
That happens commonly in Japan.
The kombu, again, there's
all sorts of levels of kombu.
This one I got from
a friend who got it.
He's a restaurant friend.
And so it's even
better than what
I can get at the fish market.
And you have pretty good
kombu here too, at Google.
So good for that.
This is going right now.
I'm going to make the
little broccoli pickle.
Everything you make
for Japanese food
is-- you want it to be
bite-sized for chopsticks.
And we use these
very-- I say we,
but not many people in Japan are
actually using these anymore.
The modernization of the
knives has happened as well.
This is a $25 knife that
my local knife maker makes.
I bring them for-- I
bring a lot of them
for doing demo-- for doing
cooking classes with students,
because I want them to
pick them up and feel them.
I'll leave it over here.
Maybe I won't pass it around.
But you can just
feel how light it is.
And so you don't get tired.
You can use it as
a paring knife.
And also, what's the
point of it is it
has a very sharp, thin blade.
And so you're not cutting
the cells of the-- you're
not smashing the cells
of the vegetable,
it's just cutting down.
We cut down straight,
down like that.
And so you're not
bruising the cells.
And because we have
a farm, we want
to be nice to the
vegetables and honor them.
So typically, I would
use some of this.
I don't know this
broccoli as well,
so I don't know
where it came from.
So I'm going to use part
of it and leave this here.
And then we're going
to boil that for-- I
just, because I grew
up in California, boil
everything for three minutes.
That's just the way we do it.
I think the grandmas in--
all the grandmas in Japan,
they're going to be
doing it way longer.
Three minutes, Noel?
Can you go?
Oh, actually, I'm
not timing this yet.
So I got it on my iPhone.
No problem.
That's what it's good for.
OK.
So that's boiling.
This is almost-- what I chose
was a representational-- we've
got a miso thing, a fish sauce
thing, a soy sauce thing,
and an umeboshi salt thing.
So the broccoli is cooking.
The dashi's almost going.
The next thing-- we're
sort of jumping around,
because that's what you
do when you're cooking.
Turnips, the tops at
this time of year,
they're not so pretty
because of the weather.
And I often use them.
This time, we're not
going to use them.
If you use them, salt
massaging them is good.
So I trim off the--
for this case,
I'm going to trim off the tops.
And again, the pretty
ones, I would use.
Today, just not
to confuse things,
because it wasn't used in
the main recipe, I won't.
And then, we have a little
brush called a tawashi.
It's made from coconut fibers.
And again, I usually bring them.
But I really pared
down on this trip,
because I tend to
have too many things.
And then, all of a sudden,
I don't have enough.
But the tawashi is a little--
you've probably seen them.
But the Turtle brand is the
only one that's actually
made with natural fibers.
And you can find them, I
think, on Amazon, actually.
And then, you scrub the
turnips with that brush.
We don't peel turnips, daikon.
Oh, city people peel.
But farmer people are
not going to peel,
because they've picked
them just recently.
Broccoli's done?
Yes.
Katsuobushi next.
Dashi.
This thing--
Now, we don't have
a drought in Japan.
It's a water country, yeah.
So I sometimes forget
about the drought situation
in California.
But we would normally run
cold water over these.
But since-- I'm
going to actually
probably use about the
same amount of water
in this little ice bath.
It's a kind of huge ice bath.
So I'm just going to chill
them down in the ice bath.
Turn this off.
All right.
And the kombu, the point
of not boiling it--
like, we're not
the kombu police--
the boiling it brings out
the neba neba, the sliminess,
which is-- it's not a big deal.
Just try not to boil it.
But there are some soups,
some nabe that we do just
leave the kombu in.
So it's not set in stone.
Minus.
So you can see how
simple this dashi is.
And you just kind of wonder,
why would people use powder.
Because powdered, as
you, I'm sure, know,
has the obligatory MSG in
it, like all Japanese food
in the supermarket.
I think every single one that
has salt in it contains MSG.
They haven't gotten
the memo about that.
But anyway--
OK.
So dashi's happening
for-- the dashi's
going to mitigate the fish
sauce and the soy sauce.
OK.
So I've already prepared
dashi, so it's here.
So we're going to
do the celery first.
Now, celery is not
really Japanese,
but I do have-- my husband
sometimes grows it,
and my friends grow it.
Not all Japanese like it.
You know, what we don't
have is a little strainer.
Do you have one more strainer,
Noel, for the broccoli?
Or, you know what, I can
just put it in a towel.
That's fine.
I got it.
Am I out of camera?
Am I all right?
Am I screwing it all up?
Sorry it's all-- it's cold.
OK.
So we have a thing called udo.
And udo is something
we typically do, like,
as kinpira, with soy sauce.
So I developed a recipe using
celery for my first book,
and it was absolutely delicious.
And so when my friend
told me-- my friend
in Noto, which is on the--
is a peninsula to the left.
So what's that?
West?
West of Tokyo,
really amazing place.
Anyway, he told me
about this recipe
for making little morning
pickles with daikon.
And I made it with celery,
because I had some really great
celery, and it was so amazing.
So that's what we're
going to make today.
And anything crunchy like
this-- so daikon, celery,
turnips, that kind of thing--
we use these little chili
Japonesa.
It's in between, like,
a Thai chili or arbol.
It's not as dark as
the arbol, not as big.
And we break them into--
and arbols are a little bit
thicker-walled.
So can you see?
Where can they see?
You break them into pieces
so that you don't-- largish
pieces, and not too much, so
you don't-- if you break--
if they're chopped too finely,
then it's going to infuse all
in the celery.
And there might be a
little-- there is, maybe,
a little more hot heat
to the celery pickles
than I would have
put in, but I think
they're still really delicious.
And the fish sauce was--
the best Vietnamese one
you can get is the crab, Three
Crabs, according to Bruce Cost.
I still-- sorry, Japanese
is the way to go.
And so we don't really
have a measuring thing.
So I suppose I could
use this tablespoon.
It's one to one
dashi and fish sauce.
So I'll just, like-- one, two.
This kind of thing,
I don't wing it.
I do, so it's a little
bit hard to measure.
But I'm up to the task.
One, two-- I used
to be a bartender.
I can figure it out.
OK.
I'm going to put this back
in the mix of tasters.
OK.
And then, you put
it in a Ziploc.
Whenever you put something
in a Ziploc, remember,
the zip is-- you don't
want to get that wet.
And you just stick it in
the Ziploc for 30 minutes,
and it's good to go.
You don't want it longer than
30 minutes unless you taste it
and you feel like it
needs more fish sauce.
Also, if you have a
strong fish sauce,
we did one part fish
sauce to two parts dashi,
because the fish
sauce was strong.
So the whole point of the dashi
is to mitigate the fish sauce.
So if you're going to
do-- like, somehow, you
wanted to leave it for
a really long time,
I would either take
off the soaking
or you add a lot more dashi.
OK?
They can also taste
that, too, I think.
But if we stick it in the
fridge for now-- yeah.
This is done.
I don't know what we do
with the dirty dishes.
Pass it to you?
No.
OK, I won't do that.
All right.
This is not boiling either.
There is no sweet spot on these.
It's either too "boily"
or not boiling enough.
All right.
Then, the broccoli also needs
to go for about 30 minutes.
So we're going to have
you taste it, maybe,
before the 30 minute mark.
But I think it's
a good idea to try
to taste some of this
with the official stuff.
Bowl.
Ice, we don't want ice.
Oh, yeah, and these, I might
use, so I'll hold on to them
just in case.
Yeah, thanks.
All right.
This one is three parts dashi
to four parts soy sauce,
and some more of these
little Japonesa chili.
Again, I don't
want to go too far.
That's done.
OK.
I'll go-- whoa-- one.
But you can see how
simple this is, and really
good with Western food too.
One-- But also, it's the--
So this soy sauce, obviously,
it's more expensive.
And I'm going to show you--
I think I priced it out--
that it's three times as
expensive as the least
expensive Kikkoman.
Now Kikkoman does
not do a bad job,
but they definitely are
not using non-GMO soybeans.
It'd be kind of impossible-- OK.
Here's another zip
locker-- because there
aren't enough non-GMO
soybeans in the United States
to supply Kikkoman.
But does anybody
have any Kikkoman?
My brother-in-law
works for them,
so I shouldn't say
that, actually.
But it's a little
bit of a gray area.
But they at least do ferment
their soy sauce for six months.
And they have an accelerated
fermentation process,
so they put it in a room.
The whole point of
the fermentation
is that it needs to go
through-- we talk about-- ooh,
water on the iPhone.
Don't want that-- needs to go
through-- sorry-- two summers.
Because the fermentation
arc happens in the summer,
because that's when
all the activity comes.
OK?
So what Kikkoman or Oriyama--
so, those kind of companies--
do is they leave
the-- oh, thanks.
OK-- they leave the soy sauce
in a summer-like environment
for six months.
And they use a super koji.
Koji is the fermentation
element material.
So they kind of speed it along.
So it's not as bad
as one would think.
Actually, they do
a fairly good job.
But for three times the
money, this is way worth it
in my mind.
OK.
So those two are done,
just a little waiting game.
And then, this is kind
of an instant pickle,
because the turnip, you're
going to salt it a little bit.
And again, if you a table salt
thing or a really fine sea
salt, the salt's going to
get into the vegetables
immediately.
And so you really want
to back off on it.
There's nothing to
squeeze out, really.
It's just getting off
the residual salt.
And so this kind of salt,
unfortunately, we're
going to not use it.
You could use it
for something else.
Then, this umeboshi is one
that I made from our ume
on the tree.
It's "sour plum" in
English, but it's actually
in an apricot family.
And you brine it.
You salt them.
And then, the brine comes up.
Then, you dry them
outside three days.
You wait for the warm weather--
the hot weather, sorry-- sunny
weather.
And then, they stay,
again, for a long time.
So commercial umeboshi
are much stronger.
They have a little more vinegar
element for preservation.
We don't put shiso
in our umeboshi,
because shiso makes
the ume quite hot pink.
And that color sort
of puts me off.
I mean, I like it in
clothes, but not in my food.
But the ume, naturally, it
starts green, but then ends up
this color, which is sort
of a softy, "pinky" mauve.
And I think it's a
really pretty color.
So I didn't really feel
like I needed the shiso.
So again, this is like one of
those, how much umeboshi you
put in depends on your mood.
That's maybe too much.
But maybe some people
can taste this too.
And this is the katsuobushi,
the real deal katsuobushi.
Again, if you're feeling it,
put lots of katsuobushi in.
My son shaved it for
me at the restaurant.
He was working.
They have shaving machine.
So it was shaved right
before New Year's.
So it's lost some of
its oomph, but still--
oh, let's put it all in.
Why not?
Because it's so good.
And then, a little bit of
soy sauce for roundness.
I really don't like
the word "umami,"
because it was
developed-- it was made up
by Ajinamoto to promote
their lovely MSG product.
But it does really
add-- there is
sort of a real phenomenon
of what it does.
So this is done.
I didn't taste it.
I bet I should taste it, right?
I think it's good.
OK.
That's done.
Those two are done.
The last thing is,
these are kind of magic.
Just a second.
These are all done.
This, I'll just consolidate.
Yep.
That's done.
Good.
All right.
Oh, this is done.
And the miso eggs came from a--
my husband put the soy sauce
eggs in the first book.
And I followed my
husband's method.
He marinates hard-boiled eggs in
soy sauce, in the refrigerator,
for his little road trips.
And he does it
for days and days.
And they start
becoming almost cheesy.
But I discovered that, actually,
I liked it for four hours only.
And then I did it with
miso, and it was so amazing.
And it's been the most
popular little appetizer
on all of the tourists.
So basically, you
just take the miso.
You flatten in your hand.
You don't need this whole--
oh, it's too late now.
It was completely
encased in miso.
On these restaurant
things, we never
have quite enough
miso to do that.
I mean, I have access to
lots and lots of miso,
because I also make it.
And because the egg has
weeped out a little bit,
it's a little bit softer.
The miso you have
access to, some
of the better misos,
their flavor is excellent,
but they're super stiff.
And so they're going to be a
little bit harder to deal with,
but their flavor is really good,
like Mr. Miso Master, whatever
his name is.
South River is, maybe,
medium consistency.
Anyway, you just
smooth around the egg,
and even if it's
not all touching.
Because it is a lot of miso.
And you guys, it's more
expensive than for me.
But you can reuse it
a number of times.
It's better to--
we have farm eggs.
And so the eggs,
the pieces come off.
You could also reuse it
for soup if you need to.
It's better with just the eggs.
Anyway, you take off the
miso after four hours.
And then, they'll hold.
And you never, never wash,
of course, the miso off.
Save this in a
Tupperware or a Ziploc.
Just a second here.
Washing hands.
Thank you, Didi.
Making a mess here.
And then, you slice it.
Can I have a little
plate, maybe?
You want to get
the egg-- thanks.
You want to get the egg
done, but not overdone.
It's a very hard-- in our
house, it's nine minutes.
Here, the eggs were cold.
So I think I went to 11.
So typically, for
cooking, you want
to use room temperature eggs.
Of course, we have our own eggs,
so we never refrigerate them
from the get-go.
And it's not good to put them
in and out and in and out.
So when you want
to use them, just
return to room temperature.
They should have a
little center of wetness.
And then, I didn't
put this in the book,
but-- oops, cancel-- a
little bit of seven spice
powder, shichimi togarashi,
is really pretty and delicious
on the eggs.
So if we cut these
a little bit more,
people could also
taste this one.
I don't know if that
tastes different.
Dashi's done.
I'll use this for
the chefs' class.
And then, you can reuse this
kombu and the katsuobushi
for-- this one, you
can dry up in a pan
and use it for a little
sprinkles on rice, add some soy
sauce, some aromatics.
Kombu, you can add to miso soup.
You can add it--
again, you can saute it
with-- you could simmer it
with soy sauce and mirin.
There's various methods.
But those are the
four things you're
going to taste with slightly
different ingredients--
the caveat.
AUDIENCE: I'm so confused about
the difference between koji
and miso.
Is koji the thing that starts
the miso [INAUDIBLE] thing?
NANCY HACHISU: Yeah.
Koji is a spore.
The confusion comes
that koji is a spore,
but it's also typically--
it's a spore that
inoculates rice, or wheat,
or barley to make miso.
For soy sauce, it's inoculated
on a wheat and soybeans.
For sake, it
inoculates on the rice.
It's a spore that
inoculates a grain.
OK?
But then, the confusion
comes, when we often
talk about the
inoculated grain as koji.
Well, it's actually rice koji.
It's actually barley koji.
It's actually something,
something koji.
But that's where
the confusion comes.
AUDIENCE: When I
go to the store,
if it says koji miso,
that's just miso?
NANCY HACHISU: It means
miso that is just miso.
It means it, maybe, has a
higher concentration of koji.
So white miso has
more koji in it.
The problem is the
labeling becomes perverted,
or "something-verted"
when it comes here,
and for various reasons--
Japanese thinking
they're making it more
understandable or Americans
thinking they're making
it more understandable.
And somehow, it's not at
all understandable, I agree,
which is a big problem about--
OK.
I'll ask you guys.
So some of us think that this
is a really super cool label,
and we want to send
the ingredients as is.
My branding friend says,
no, all the products
should look like the yuzu bottle
so that they're all like Thai
Kitchen, all discernible.
It's was such a conundrum.
But anyway, if you have
any thoughts on that,
just email me.
AUDIENCE: But when you do
some of the preserving,
do you do anything
beforehand to balance out
the sour that happens
in the process or any
of the fermentation that
happens in the process?
NANCY HACHISU: Kind
of a big question.
So he's wondering-- OK.
If you're doing-- so
you want the sourness
for the lacto-fermentation.
And so that's what
you're looking for.
And if you put too much salt
on, you don't get the sourness.
So in process, there's
always a percentage of salt
you put in for, like, the
napa cabbage pickles, hakusai,
and/or takuan.
But takuan has rice bran
raw, non-toasted rice bran.
And so it's a little bit
harder to get the brine up.
Fish is just heavily,
heavily salted.
And then, the adjustment
comes after the thing is done.
So if your thing came
out, whether it's
nukazuke pickles, or takuan,
or hokusai, it came out
and it's not as
salty as you wish,
then, you drizzle soy sauce on.
If it's too salty,
you might leach it out
with a little water, but it's a
little bit difficult with some
of these things.
With fish, totally, you're going
to leach it out with water.
Or you're going to soak it
in sake leaves to suck up.
Sake leaves suck
up the salt. That's
a pretty common thing for
fish or a vegetable thing.
AUDIENCE: Do you give a good
source for umeboshi paste in--
NANCY HACHISU: I
think that Gold Mine
is where you really want to go.
There's a woman in San
Francisco who's selling it.
And I bought it for a friend,
because I couldn't find mine.
He's looking for umeboshi paste.
You're not going to want
me to tell you this,
but it's actually not so
hard to make them yourself
if you catch the season in June.
And I don't know how easy
it is to get organic ume.
There's a lot of
people in the area.
Like, I keep hearing
about somebody.
There was a lot of
Japanese farmers.
In the 1900s, the Japanese came.
They planted all these.
There's a lot of trees that
are not being harvested.
But you know, you have
just by word of mouth.
But frankly, in Japan, I make
apricot or a raspberry jam
from-- oh, sorry--
from non-organic fruit,
because my tree's
not fruiting enough.
And I really want to jam.
And I have organic sugar.
So it's a trade-off.
But otherwise, Gold Mine.
The one in San Francisco
was really expensive,
but umeboshi will be expensive.
It will be, because it's
kind of precious in a way.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
Everyone, please--
NANCY HACHISU: You're welcome.
Thank you for coming.
FEMALE SPEAKER: --join me.
And thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
NANCY HACHISU: Thank
you. [INAUDIBLE].